Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to 'Carrots and Cream.'
Now this game was recommended to me because,
they said it was bizarre,
and intriguing, and "right up my alley".
And when I went to the website all the other reviews said that it was
"a life changing, mind-blowing experience," and I don't know how true that is,
But let's go, because I hear a pot of- (Chewing noises in-game) Ohhh... Oh God! Aaah... Stop it!
Ahh it's so gross stop that!
Ewww...?!
I was... I was a bit disturbed by the pot of what I was hoping stew...Oh god..
And now I'm thinking that it was a pot of boiling blood, probably?
Oh geez... Hi, how's it going? Is that a shovel? I'm gonna assume that's a shovel and I need to...
Yep, right on target, a little bit off but...
Oh god...
Oh god... Ah...
I mean, it seems like normal, everyday life,
but it's just a slightly perturbing setting, what with the...
I'm gonna assume it's a river of flowing blood, now.
And then the guy that was enjoying carrots and cream
FAR too much, in the midst of my ear,
And now we're just gonna be picking more carrots so we can do this all over again.
Is this the-...Is this the existential crisis?
The endless cycle of carrots and cream?
I don't even wanna know where I get the cream.
*Laughing uncomfortably* I don't wanna know where I get the cream...
Is that gonna be part of this game later?
Ah shit, I missed!
There we go!
That was more on target.
Definitely not cutting my carrot in half.
Oh, we're done! Oh, we got enough!
A little garden of five carrots is more than enough...
Alright... Why are you shaking so much?
I think this guy is shaking from lack of nutrition
from everything else he hasn't had... in his life.
Oh god.
Oh. Well this seems...This seems perfectly normal!
Nothing weird about this!
Just chopping carrots into a bowl of what I assume to be cream...
What type of cream, we aren't going to discuss!
But it's a type of cream, while the perpetual...like,
fountain of youth behind me is bubbling furiously away...
And I'm assuming there's a numerous number of dead bodies
in the closets, and... IN EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY IN THE HOUSE
there's the murdered members of my family, because I'm clearly INSANE.
Yay!
This is a game that I- the- i- th- What's weird about it is that it's sooo...
Kinda normal?
And yet it's presented in a way that's VERY disturbing.
Like-- something that-- obviously what I've been doing is I've just been gardening up carrots.
And yet...
I am DEEPLY perturbed.
Oh hello.
Oh.
Is that a worm?
Why is it breathing?
Why is the ground shaking so much?
WHY DO WE LIVE IN AN EARTHQUAKE?
Does it do.. Oh, okay!
Augh!
My- My poor little baby!
Oh no!
I didn't know that I was supposed to be racing the gun here.
Okay so I gotta inch my way, I'm assuming...
I'm assuming this worm is gonna infect- oh no.
Oh, this worm is just gonna eat through.
I thought, I thought for a second that the worm was gonna infect one of the carrots.
And this this was gonna be the start of the Zombie Apocalypse as this guy
with his unhealthy obsession with carrots and cream.
Decides to accidentally ingest one of these horrible worms.
That's getting a little close buddy, you wanna be-
I don't even think this guy is going for the carrots.
Somehow he has- OOHH!
He's eaten so many carrots...
He's gained X-Ray vision and he can see through the ground where this worm is.
So he knows and he's trying to stop it from taking all of his crops.
But you won't stop ME buddy-boo!
I know EXACTLY what I'm doing in my life!
I don't know exactly what I'm doing in this game...
But I like it! ...  I think?
I think this is- Oh, hello.
Oohh!
Woo! Look at Big Mama Carrot over there!
Ohh hey baby~
How you doin'?
Oh boy!
My- oh.
Eugh.. I was just..Dangling it with the end of- Oh no..
OHH!
I was right!!
Oh he's gonna eat this carrot and he's gonna become infested!
Oh the poor carrot of..
Like, the GLORIOUS carrot. That's a gigantic carrot.
But I knew that this guy's unholy obsession with these carrots was gonna be the end of him some day.
I mean,
He may have great vision that can see through the ground,
but he can't see why kids love the taste of Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
Uhhm..
Eugh..
Eugh... Eugh.. Eugh.
*Worm Squeaks* OH-HO GOD!
WHY IS IT SCREAMING?
Oh god!
Why is there THAT much blood?!
I know this guy's clinically insane but..
W-Why wouldn't he stop when he sees a fountain of blood?!
*Boiling Water noise*
*In-Game sigh*
DON'T MOAN IN MY EAR!
OH THAT'S IT?!
WHAT?!
Huehuewaha?
It's a- but- THERE'S BLOOD IN THE CREAM!
Thanks for playing?!
Fuck you for changing my goddamn life!
What the fuck just happened?
I don't know..
I don't know what I accidentally led you guys into!
I don't know what happened!
I don't know what to DO with my life now!
I have to go on and play more games today!
Knowing that this experience befell me.
What? You want an intelligent recap of what just happened?
YOU WERE THERE!
YOU WERE THERE, MAN!
You had to experience it WITH me!
It was bizarre because it seems so normal!
And just a few different twists and turns and different sound effects makes it a bizarre and horrifying experience.
But that's 'Carrots and Cream' I guess! So..
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
As always I'll see you in the next video.
Bye bye...
*Loud squeaky scream sound*